MAR-A-LAGO IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> Dana: DAVID SPUNT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE ISSUE OF PROBABLE CAUSE IS
SOMETHING I'M THINKING ABOUT
EARLIER BECAUSE WE TALKED ABOUT
THE SEARCH WARRANT AFFIDAVITS
BUT IF IT'S ABOUT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, THEN MAYBE WE WILL
NEVER KNOW BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
DECLASSIFIED THEM.
ARE THEY AVAILABLE TO LOOK AT?
>> IT'S A NUMBER OF ISSUES AND
YOU BROUGHT UP ONE OF THEM IS
THAT THE PRESIDENT THE ULTIMATE
AUTHORITY ON WHAT'S CLASSIFIED
AND NOD.
THERE IS A PROCEDURE, BUT LET'S
BE CLEAR, IT'S UNPRECEDENTED AND
WE'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
YOU BETTER PRODUCE COOKIES AND
I'VE DONE MANY OF THESE.
I'VE BEEN A FEDERAL AGENT FOR 20
YEARS.
WEREN'T SO FANCY AND WE RODE IT
OUT BUT I'M LOOKING AT THIS YEAR
AND OKAY, YOU'RE ABOUT TO BURN
DOWN THE CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC
LIKE A LOSER AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OFFICE.
WHAT IS HE PRODUCING THERE?
OF THE RUSSIAN NUCLEAR CODES?
DON'T SEE THAT.
UNITED STATES NUCLEAR CODES?
IS THIS A FILE ON WHERE
AMELIA EARHART -- I DON'T SEE
ANY OF THAT.
ALL I SEE IS MAY BE SOME
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW IF THEY WERE
DECLASSIFIED OR NOT AND I SAY
OKAY, HE HAD SOMETHING HE
SHOULDN'T HAVE AND THERE'S A
PROCESS, THIS SAME PROCESS WITH
EVERY OTHER PRESIDENT.
MERRICK GARLAND WANTS TO BURN
THE REPUBLIC DOWN AND INFURIATE
100 PLUS AMERICANS OVER A
LEATHER BOUND BOX OF DOCUMENTS
AND WHAT IS THIS?
ANCHORMAN?
A COLLECTION OF LEATHER BOUND
BOOKS AND FIND COLOGNE?
I'M NOT A COMEDIAN.
BUT THIS IS IT, YOU'RE GOING TO
BURN THE COUNTRY DOWN OVER WHAT?
THIS?
YOU BETTER PRODUCE SOMETHING.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS IS
LIKE A BOX OF DOCUMENTS.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL ACTUALLY
SEE THE BOX UNTIL THEY DECIDE TO
MAKE IT.
>> Greg: I HAVE TO DISAGREE
WITH DAN, THIS IS BIGGER THAN
WATERGATE.
BIGGER THAN 9/11, VIETNAM, THE
CANCELLATION OF THE FACTS OF
LIFE'S.
IF HE WENT HOME WITH EXTREMELY
SENSITIVE MATERIAL AND WON'T
GIVE THEM BACK IN THE LAKE --
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU WOULD DO
THIS?
DO YOU THINK HE'S PLANNING ON
SELLING THE SECRETS TO RUSSIA OR
GOING TO BUILD HIS OWN MISSILE?
HE'S REALLY GOT THE BUNKERS,
IT'S A GOLF COURSE JOKE.
BUT THIS DOESN'T SOUND AT ALL
HYSTERICAL.
IF IT'S NOT AN AFFIDAVIT, I
COINED THE PHRASE.
YOU CAN'T TAKE ANYTHING
SERIOUSLY WHEN IT SOUNDS LIKE
EVERY HOAX THAT HAD COME BEFORE.
THE HOAX THING IS LIKE IT STARTS
OFF WITH A BIG FIREBALL AND THEN
GOING TO COOK HIM A TEXT, TAKE
ON TWITTER.
THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN.
AND THEN AS IT GOES AWAY IT,
SUDDENLY MEDIA HAS TO TURN ON
THE SUPPORTERS AND SAY THEY ARE
DANGEROUS.
I HEARD AND ON THE NETWORK.
THESE THREE WORDS PREFACE EVERY
SINGLE STORY THAT TURNED OUT NOT
TRUE.
IF IT'S TRUE, THIS COULD BRING
HIM DOWN.
TO YOUR POINT, THIS IS GOING TO
BE ABOUT PROCESS, IT'S GOING TO
BE THE MOST BORING THING EVER A
HE SAID, SHE SAID ABOUT
PAPERWORK.
THE DULLEST VIOLATION -- IT'S
ANOTHER PROCESS CRIME.
ADMINISTRATIVE GOOF.
HE DIDN'T FOLLOW THE PROCESS
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT IS THE
PROCESS.
MEANWHILE, ALL YOU'RE LEFT WITH
IS MERRICK GARLAND LOOKING LIKE
A DEPRESSED WILL CARTOON AND
DONALD TRUMP ABSORBS ALL THE
ENERGY.
HE DECIDES I'M GOING TO RUN
AGAIN AND IS GOING TO USE ALL
THE ENERGY TO WIN OR MAYBE HE
WON'T.
THE GUYS COMING OUT ON TOP RIGHT
NOW IS HIM BECAUSE THIS IS
HILARIOUS.
>> SOME CONCESSIONS ABOUT HOW DO
YOU PROVE INTENT.
WE DON'T KNOW HARDLY ANYTHING
BUT HE USED TO WORK AT THE DOJ,
HOW TO PROVE INTENT.
>> YOU DO NOT HAVE THE MENTAL
STATE EVIDENCE TO PROVE THAT
THERE WAS INTENT.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SHOW THAT
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF HAS THE
INTENT TO TAKE AND KEEP AND
REFUSED TO GIVE BACK CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL.
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE WHETHER HE
DESIGNATED OR DECLASSIFIED, IT'S
WHETHER OR NOT HE HAD THE
INTENTION AND OVERT ACTS BY THE
PRESIDENT, THE FACT OF THE
THEORY THAT HE HAD THE INTENTION
TO COMMIT A CRIME.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF THAT.
>> SINCE MONDAY NIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY OF THAT, A SEARCH
WARRANT AND DAN POINTED OUT IT'S
PRETTY BIG.
>> I'LL POINT YOU TO ATTACHMENT
B PARAGRAPH C.
ANY GOVERNMENT OR PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS CREATED BETWEEN
JANUARY 20TH, 2017 AND
JANUARY 20TH 2021, THAT'S EVERY
RECORD CREATED DURING THE ENTIRE
PRESIDENCY.
ANDY McCARTHY TEXTED ME ABOUT
THIS AND HE SAID THAT'S NOT
EVIDENCE OF A CRIME AT ALL.
IT'S NOT MUCH LESS A CRIME OF
MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, IT'S EVIDENCE OF A
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT
VIOLATION AND THAT'S NOT A
CRIMINAL STATUTE.
THESE SEARCH WARRANTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT EVIDENCE OF
CRIME.
BUT THIS WARRANT ALLOWS THEM TO
TAKE EVERY SHRED OF PAPER
RELATED TO TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S CLASSIFIED
TO CONNECT INFORMATION.
ROUGHLY 30 FBI AGENTS SHOULD
HAVE BEEN CARRYING RODS AND
REELS AND BUCKETS OF BAIT GIVEN
WHAT THEY ARE GOING IN TO
MAR-A-LAGO LOOKING FOR.
AND HE SAID OVER OVER AGAIN, THE
WIND NOW IS THE JANUARY 6TH
INVESTIGATION WITHIN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
PERIOD, END OF STATEMENT TO
MUFFLE
THE WINE NOW
WHY NOW, WHY THEY EXECUTEDTHE CR
HIS PHONE.
CONGRESSMAN PERRY WAS THE ONE
WHO INTRODUCED THE ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWYER TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JOHN EASEMENT -- AND NOT JOHN,
JEFFREY CLARK.
THEY ALL HAD SEARCH WARRANTS
EXECUTED ON THEM IN JUNE.
JEFFREY CLARK I BELIEVE WAS
PULLED OUT OF HIS HOUSE.
IN PAJAMAS WHEN THEY WERE
SEARCHING HIM.
IF YOU HAVE SUBPOENAS NOW,
SEARCH WARRANTS, SEARCH WARRANT,
SUBPOENA, SUBPOENA, SCOTT PERRY,
THE PHONE, NOW THIS.
THIS IS -- THEY ARE THE GARBAGE
MEN.
THEY ARE COLLECTING EVIDENCE TO
FUNNEL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO SUPPORT THE
JANUARY 6TH INVESTIGATION.
AND HE SAID THAT ALL ALONG AND
THAT ONE LITTLE PARAGRAPH SEEMS
TO INDICATE THAT.
THEY TAKE ANYTHING.
>> Dana: JESSICA?
>> Jessica: ALL OF TRUMP'S
TALKING POINTS HAVE EXPLODED IN
HIS FACE, WHETHER ON SOMETHING
HE RELEASED ON THE TRUE SOCIAL
OR THE PEOPLE HE HAD DISPERSED
ALL OVER TELEVISION TO
PROLIFERATE HIS LINES INCLUDING
HIS OWN CHILDREN SAYING HE
DIDN'T GET A COPY OF THE
WARRANT, THE ATTORNEY CONFIRMED
IT ON OTHER NETWORKS.
THEY HAD THE WARRANT THERE.
HE SAID PRESIDENT OBAMA --
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID THIS TOO.
HE TOOK THE NUKE MATERIALS OUT
OF HIS BACK POCKET -- NOT TRUE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA FULFILLED
PROTOCOL 30 MILLION DOCUMENTS
WENT THROUGH THEM TO CHICAGO
FOLLOWING PROTOCOL.
RESPECT FOR THE LAW IN THE WAY
THINGS ARE DONE.
IT IS TO MIND GLOWINGLY ARROGANT
I THINK TO SIT HERE AND SAY I
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON AND
TO CALL THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA A
LOSER, I THINK THAT'S THE WORD
THAT YOU USED.
>> Dan: HE'S A GREAT LOSER.
ACTUAL LOSER.
>> Jessica: I KNOW LOSERS IN
MY LIFE, AND MERRICK GARLAND --
>> Dan: HE SPRINTED DOWN THE
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC
TARGETING AND YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S IN THERE EITHER.
>> Jessica: BUT I CAN AT LEAST
SAY I KNOW --
>> Dan: I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP.
ACTUAL PICTURES OF HIM WITH
SMOKING CRACK.
THE PEARL CLUTCHING ABOUT HOW HE
WAS A STANDARD AND PARAGON OF
JUSTICE ON THE DEMOCRATS RED
BEARD AND HILLARY CLINTON --
>> Jessica: HERE WE GO, OH, MY
GOD.
9 MINUTES AND, HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Dan: THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AS PARAGONS --
>> Jessica: I SAT THERE AND
LISTEN TO YOU.
LET ME FINISH.
OKAY, THE POINT HERE -- OKAY.
THE POINT HERE IS THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HAS NO RESPECT
FOR THE RULE OF LAW AND HE SHONE
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
HE CALLED BRAD RAFFENSPERGER, HE
WANTED TO STOP THE ACCOUNT IN
ARIZONA AND CONTINUE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED ON
GENERATOR SIX WHERE HE WANTED
MIKE PENCE TO DECERTIFY AN
AMERICAN ELECTION.
HE WANTED YOUR YOUR VOTES NOT TO
COUNT.
REFUSING TO COMPLY WITH THE
RULES THAT EVERY PRESIDENT HAD
TO COMPLY WITH.
HE DID NOT COMPLY.
NO, I'M NOT!
>> Dan: HE ACTUALLY MET WITH
THEM.
>> Jessica: AND THEN AFTER
THAT JAMES WHO WAS THE AGENT
INVOLVED WITH THIS --
>> Dana: IT WAS SIX WEEKS
SINCE THE END OF JUNE.
>> Dagen: IF IT WAS SO
URGENT --
>> Jessica: WAS THERE A
SUBPOENA IGNORED BY THE BURISMA?
>> Dagen: THEY HAD
CONVERSATIONS AFTER THE SUBPOENA
YOU DON'T KNOW IF THEY COMPLIED
OR NOT.
>> Greg: THIS WEEK HAS BEEN SO
MUCH FUN WITH THIS STORY BECAUSE
NO ONE'S GETTING HURT AND IT'S
ABOUT PAPERWORK!
>> Jessica: ACTUALLY THE FBI
AGENTS IN CINCINNATI --
>> Dan: THE GUY WAS SHOT DEAD.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEANT, JESSICA, DON'T THROW
THAT.
>> Jessica: I DIDN'T HEAR
TRUMP CONDEMN IT.
A LITTLE BIT SMALLER